this week on bloomberg green lights
camera climate action we focus in on how
the entertainment industry is trying to
make itself and the world more
sustainable the tv and film industry is
worth spends about 200 billion on um
content every year and that's a huge
amount of purchase power to shift
economies shift markets and catalyze
innovation one of the most obvious
things and that anybody can recognize
when they go to concerts all they have
to do is look down at their feet at the
end of the night and lights them up they
see all the plastic on the ground and so
that's an immediate thing that you can
do is just eliminate all that single-use
plastic waste as much as possible it's
through storytelling and connecting
people
through these stories that we can talk
about larger issues so you know this is
a film for example about jacques yves
cousteau but it's about how we
are going to
experience and protect the environment
from documentaries focusing on climate
change to musicians looking to make
touring carbon neutral we get to the
heart of the action from bloomberg's
european headquarters in london i'm ed
ludlow
[Music]
let's start off with the music industry
touring is an integral part in an
artist's career but it can have a big
impact on the environment traveling
racks up a high carbon footprint but
there's ways to reduce that and that's
where charity reverb comes in they've
partnered with artists like dave
matthews band harry styles and dead and
company to reduce concert and tall
footprints i spoke to co-founder adam
gardner
reverb's a non-profit organization that
my wife and i founded in 2004 um you
know i come from the music world she
came from the environmental world so as
we got married it was both a literal and
figurative marriage of our two worlds
where i was feeling
badly about my carbon footprint and my
environmental impact on the road as a
member of guster have been touring now
for 30 years
and she as an environmentalist was
concerned that at the time especially in
the early 2000s that the environmental
movement was very insular and a bunch of
people agreeing with each other but was
wasn't reaching the mainstream audiences
uh so our two concerns came together in
this nonprofit organization we started
to help both
uh you know touring and music in general
be more sustainable but also use that
incredible cultural power that music has
to influence millions and millions of
music fans to take real action for the
climate and other environmental causes
well let's talk in basic terms what we
literally mean here we're talking about
being on the road touring going on get
going to gigs you know from the band's
perspective we're talking about you know
on the lower end everyone piling into a
to a minivan or into a into a vw
and and hitting the road or if you're a
superstar some of these mega coaches
that are in convoy or even private jets
what are some of the kind of the
practical steps that you're able to help
musicians work on to reduce their carbon
footprint
i mean one of the most obvious things
and that anybody can recognize when they
go to concerts all they have to do is
look down at their feet at the end of
the night and lights up they see all the
plastic on the ground and so that's an
immediate thing that you can do is just
eliminate all that single-use plastic
waste as much as possible on a touring
on end of it as an artist you can you
know look at your hospitality riders and
say hey instead of asking for cases of
single-use plastic water bottles let's
replace that with reusables and have
water filling stations we also provide
water filling refill stations out front
for the fans and reusable water bottles
through a program they call rock and
refill
in partnership with nalgene and we make
a tor artist branded bottle i'll offer
that to fans for a donation those
donations can go to local organizations
along the tour that we invite out to the
shows or they can go to uh
supporting carbon fighting projects uh
that can neutralize uh greenhouse gas
pollution etc uh while also eliminating
a lot of single-use plastic water
bottles to date since we've called it
rock and refill um
we've eliminated over four million
single-use plastic water bottles at
concerts alone so that's a really
obvious one there's lots of different
things you can look at your merchandise
you look at your catering and your food
and where it's being sourced from what
other you know forms of waste are
happening out there can we you know
avoid idling the tour buses and trucks
wherever possible is there shore power
available at the venues a lot of it is
working hand in hand with the touring
industry it's you know
we're all interdependent um so really
working with every facet of the industry
we possibly can and then also related
industries like hotels
um trucking
merchandise
so yeah there's a lot of different
aspects to this and what's neat about it
from a musician's standpoint as a
musician myself
i it's a i can actually walk my talk you
know
there are a lot of causes that i feel
passionate about i want to
help use the fact that i have a
microphone and help them
but what's interesting with the
environment is that we can actually say
hey tonight's show is powered by wind
power we're using all reusables
backstage our food is sourced from x
miles from the venue all right will you
please join us and it's this nice
positive communal effort
um and we're able to then
engage fans again from my wife's
perspective on the environmental
movement side how do we support
nonprofit groups and environmental
causes across the country and now
globally
and use the attention in light that is
shining on an artist like billy eilish
or maroon 5 and shine it on the efforts
of organizations on the ground in their
own communities so you're leaving this
wake of goodness behind you as you're
touring and instead of leaving
a wake of plastic waste and and carbon
emissions we're trying to make that flip
that on its head and leave
a wake of positive support volunteers
and local organizations neutralizing
more emissions than we're creating on
tour
etc
well let's talk about the artists the
musicians what kind of star power
is behind this initiative who's on board
oh you want me to name drop right now
it's name drop let's do it
sure i mean we've been very lucky some
of the first artists we work with uh
back in 2004 and five we still work with
today like dave matthews band route 5
john mayer uh and now we have some new
folks like uh and jack johnson new folks
like billy eilish and sean mendes and
harry styles team impala
um even broadway now hadestown which is
a you know eight-time tony award-winning
broadway musicals on tour and and
working with us so it's exciting there's
a lot of
momentum dead company uh you know a lot
of i can name many many we've been on
hundreds and hundreds of tours now since
we started
where is there still work to be done
though i mean is it with the musicians
or the artists or do you find generally
speaking that it's the fans you know
those that are paying for the tickets
that need to go to the concerts go to
the venues and kind of act in a
different way behave in a different way
it's all of it um but you know if you're
talking from a climate perspective
carbon emissions
75 or more of the carbon footprint of a
concert event is the fans traveling to
and from it
so there's a real opportunity there the
challenge what where where things need
to change is the access to public
transportation especially for larger
outdoor venues in the summertime that
tend to be 40 plus miles out of city
centers
that don't have easy access to
public transit so that is a huge
area of improvement that can happen and
is being worked on now in the meantime
as a non-profit working with the artists
we set up carpooling in you know
incentives get caught carpooling and
you'll win front row tickets these sorts
of things um and again
we travel we actually insert reverb
staff members onto the tour and they're
folded into the crew just like a guitar
tech or sound person but their job is
solely to handle everything backstage
and make sure everything is happening as
it should with everything that we
advance here in portland maine in our
home office
with local farm food for catering
picking up compost if it doesn't already
exist in commercial facilities there
handling all the all the various things
we can do to limit the footprint
backstage and at the same time set up an
eco village action village for fans to
engage with local national and global
organizations at the shows and yeah
that's where the real positive impacts
can happen so while we're trying to
reduce the negative impacts backstage
behind the scenes we can more than make
up for that out front with all the fan
engagements and all the dollars that we
can raise
um for projects we have a new campaign
called the music climate revolution with
the goal that we launched during kovid
with the goal of making music
more positive for the climate than
negative and that's not just tournament
that's recorded in music as well so we
have
warner music national involved we have
beggars group out of the uk involved um
we have management companies etc so that
it's it's exciting the momentum is
really building
coming up a screen new deal the film and
tv industry looks at new ways to cut its
carbon footprint we'll have that
discussion next this is bloomberg
[Music]
welcome back to bloomberg green i'm ed
ludlow in london let's get to our weekly
check-in on climate news with jennifer
sabasage
here's all the climate news you need to
know this week a failure to respond to
climate change could lead to australia's
sovereign debt costs spiraling
government officials say the country's
cost of capital would increase by a
hundred basis points in an adverse
climate change scenario without a
strategy to reach its net zero emissions
target the warning comes as investors
are starting to amp up pressure on coal
reliant nations also the organization
that regulates shipping made little
progress towards decarbonizing the
industry during a series of meetings
last week talks hosted by the united
nations international maritime
organization failed to get agreement on
a non-binding proposal on zero emissions
the imo has yet to set solid rules or
even a target that would get the
industry back on track and finally bp is
planning to build a green hydrogen
facility in northeast england that could
start producing the gas by 2025 part of
a massive project to help the oil major
transition toward cleaner sources of
energy the high green t-side proposal
follows one made earlier this year to
develop a blue hydrogen facility in the
same location london-based bp says it
wants to capture a 10 percent share of
core hydrogen markets over the next
decade and i'm jennifer zabasaja and
that's your green brief ed
thanks to jennifer savazaga the film and
television industry can be well a dirty
business at least in terms of carbon
emissions one average tent pole film
production generates nearly 3 000 tons
of co2 and fuel used on productions is
equivalent to 3.4 million miles driven
by a passenger car this according to the
organization albert which is part of the
british academy of film and television
arts but the industry is trying to
become more sustainable both on set and
in terms of the kind of content it's
producing bloomberg sarah rappaport
spoke to carys taylor from albert to
find out more
typically we find that energy usage and
transport are kind of the highest areas
of impact with the production but of
course it depends on the production
method
we find that um the typical
average hour of tv contributes to about
9.2 tons of carbon emissions per hour
last year we saw you know an atypical
year with production methods really
altering as a result of the pandemic and
they reduce down to sort of 4.4 tons of
carbon emissions per hour of tv
and that is a reflection of the
reduction of air travel so if if you're
looking to reduce your impacts as a tv
producer you should most commonly you
need to look at your transport and your
energy usage so travel less or use
hybrid cars or ways to do it yeah i
think electric vehicles um are a good
solution
and rail travel shared transport
interestingly from the pandemic we saw
whilst we saw a reduction in air travel
we saw an increase in car travel
because of sort of car sharing wasn't
really an option um if increasingly you
know the grid infrastructure is
improving um particularly in the uk um
electric vehicles will be a really good
solution in future so can those pandemic
changes actually stay around
we hope so um we are looking at the data
that's coming in this year through our
calculator and early signs showing that
a lot of those practices have been
retained um and so we are seeing a lower
um
emission intensity per hour of tv so far
but i don't want to speak too soon all
right you were just a cop what was that
like
oh it was intense um
we had several events across the first
week and we announced a really
significant climate content pledge
which the major broadcasters in the uk
and ireland signed up to
it was intended to be a global pledge
and so we're inviting
international broadcasters um to join in
um and um it was all about you know
weaving climate content into you know
all genres it's not just natural history
and news content it has to do the heavy
lifting we have to appeal to all
audiences to bring them along on this
journey so how can film and tv actually
change behavior well we've seen examples
of cultural change from tv and film in
the past for example the
80s sitcom in the us cheers
developed the concept of the drink
driving
the designated driver and reduced
drink driving related fatalities at the
time this is a real world example of
film and tv making an impact exactly um
and you know blue planet has
been referenced a lot for changing
consumers behavior toward plastics um
we need to do much more of this kind of
thing we need to embed it in all kinds
of content
so that we're reaching all kinds of
audiences to come along on the journey
to the transition to net zero how can
film and tv be a leader in this
transition
i think we we've got a lot to be proud
of already
we've reduced our impact and we've found
new ways to innovate um the the tv and
film industry is worth spends about 200
billion on um content every year and
that's a huge amount of purchase power
to shift economies shift markets and
catalyze innovation
we are already seeing that a lot of
productions are now looking at switching
diesel generators to hydrogen generators
or biofuel generators
and we can really you know catalyze that
change and shift culture
that was sarah rappaport speaking with
charis taylor the director of bafta's
albert
coming up we take an inside look at the
film becoming kosto and dive into the
life of the famed oceanographer and
environmentalist this is bloomberg green
[Music]
welcome back to bloomberg green i'm ed
ludlow in london becoming cousteau is a
new documentary that examines the life
of celebrated oceanographer and
environmentalist jacques cousteau
directed by academy award nominee liz
garbus bloomberg sarah rappaport dives
into the undersea world of the man who
alerted the world about warming of the
oceans before climate change dominated
headlines around the world
so i know you have thoughts about the
world's resources being used up and
you've seen it happening year after year
and
apparently a lot of people who should
have didn't
do you have anything you want to say
about that
well
i was
already involved in
how to say scanning the possibilities of
extracting energy from the sea
this was a choice that i made
many years ago
but what i
was shocked by is the speed and the
shamelessness with which
the industrial interests have thrown to
the wastebasket all the environmental
measures
that had been very laboriously taken
that was oceanographer and
environmentalist jack custo a new
documentary about his life called
becoming gusto the film looks at his
journey from an explorer of the
underwater world to his crusade to
protect it producer mirador chandra
spoke to bloomberg about the process of
making the documentary and how film can
change the world
i think that it's through storytelling
and connecting people
through these stories that we can talk
about larger issues so you know this is
a film for example about jacques eve
cousteau but it's about how we
um
are going to
experience and protect the environment
you know and that speaks to the
zeitgeist of what we're talking about
today once one of the most famous people
in the world for his tv projects
becoming castel looks to introduce him
to a whole new audience i think that
with the cops summit his message is more
important than ever because
of several reasons i mean we've sort of
forgotten his legacy and that he was
really sounding the alarm
50 years ago so to have that kind of
historic um understanding uh that it's
that we were talking about this before
climate change and before you know
talking about greenhouse gases was part
of our lexicon puts it into perspective
that we cannot wait any longer what did
you find surprising in learning more
about giacasto well i found it
surprising that he
invented the aqualung which is the
precursor to scuba
that was pretty exciting that he was
such a he was an inventor
that he was in the french navy i didn't
know about that um you know my knowledge
of him really started when he was a
television celebrity and from his tv
shows he gained a platform that he later
used to speak up about climate change
non-renewable resources are depleted
biodiversity shrinks to alarming levels
energy is in unreasonable demand
and above all
the melting of glaciers and of ice caps
and catastrophic highs of the ocean
level has already begun that was custo
at the earth summit in 1992. 30 years
later his message about protecting the
planet is more relevant than ever for
bloomberg green i'm sarah papoort
[Music]
that was bloomberg's sarah rappaport
let's keep it on documentaries burning
is a dock that focuses on australia's
catastrophic black summer bushfire
season from 2019 to 2020 12 million
acres went up in flames during the
disaster eva orna is the director and
producer of the film and she spoke with
bloomberg green's aaron rutkoff
i live in la and i was watching it
unfold from a distance and i think it
was august 2019 i saw the first thing on
probably cnn or something saying the
fires had started in australia and as
greg mullins says in the filming of
fires happen in australia we're a fire
prone country but this was something
different and i remember at the time
being like oh it's august it's not even
spring it's actually winter when the
fires were starting which is
unprecedented and incredibly early um
so it was on my radar and in october i
saw
again from la sydney was completely
covered in smoke which i'd never seen in
my lifetime um and by chance i was going
home as i do my summers in australia to
visit family so i arrived back in
december and i was there december
january so i was there through the brunt
of it um
and it was it was just unbelievable i
mean the whole it felt like the whole
country was burning everyone was
impacted a lot of friends and family
um lost homes and just our public radio
abc we were driving around a lot
and we listened to it all the time when
we drive and it was like an emergency
radio station it was just constantly
about evacuations and fires so it was
that was shocking but i think the thing
that really threw me over the edge was
on december 27 in melbourne my hometown
where i lived for 34 years it was um 47
degrees celsius
and i lived there for 34 years and it
never got above 44 degrees which was
generally one week in february in late
summer so this was early summer
and you know anecdotally that's a three
degree
temperature increase in my lifetime and
that's not the science it's one and a
half degrees that we've increased
temperature but in what is ground zero
for climate change the temperature has
actually increased three degrees in my
hometown and everyone was kind of
walking around
in that australian kind of laconic
relaxed way going yeah it's really hot
and i was kind of like guys it's like
baghdad what is happening here um so
that was one of the moments that really
affected me and then you know being in
sydney in january and the whole city was
in smoke again so i think by the time
you know we got on a plane to go home to
l.a i was kind of like i think i think
there's a film here
but i thought i always thought from the
beginning it shouldn't just be stories
about fires and victims it needed to be
about climate change and it needed to be
all-encompassing
that was ava orna the executive producer
and director of burning let's keep it on
documentaries and the way they can shed
light on the impact of climate change
bloomberg green is launching a
competition for filmmakers and one of
the judges is our own john frah and he
joins us now the obvious place to start
what was the reasoning behind a green
docks competition well storytelling is
one of the best ways to bring the
climate crisis and climate solutions i'm
home to people it's what we try to do in
bloomberg green
every day and it's what other media
outlets try to do all the time as well
but you know climate change lends itself
especially well to a visual story
storytelling um approach um and we
thought what better way to give a
platform some of the most interesting
young and emerging documentary
filmmakers out there than to launch this
prize for those filmmakers what are the
criteria
well i mean it's that's 10 minutes
including the credits
and you know we're looking for
interesting documentaries that bring
home the the nature of the urgency of
the climate crisis they could talk about
the um climate solutions um
that's pretty much it really it's sort
of it's a broad
category uh it's a broader way of
defining it unfortunately bloomberg
employees can't apply it so you'll have
to put your your ambitions to one side
well in support when will i know the
winner of this competition yeah so the
closing date is the end of march and
then we plan to announce the uh the five
finalists the five top documentaries at
our green docks film festival uh in new
york at the end of april where we'll
also uh announce the winner uh who will
win an award of twenty-five thousand
dollars our thanks to bloomberg senior
executive editor john fr
so that's how the world of entertainment
is looking to drive the narrative on a
more sustainable future that's it for
this week's edition of bloomberg green
but you can keep the conversation going
by following us on youtube instagram and
twitter climate this is bloomberg green
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]